this week water levels in the Great Salt
Lake in Utah hit an all-time low it is
the second time in less than a year that
the largest natural lake west of the
Mississippi reached record low water
levels the West is in the grip of a mega
drought made worse by climate change and
as John Blackstone reports the drying
lake is having a dramatic impact on its
surrounding environment
the lone kayaker on Utah's Great Salt
Lake is capturing a developing climate
disaster Brian footman from a company
called Earth views is using a 360 degree
camera so anyone on the internet can see
what's left as the lake continues to
shrink so 30 years ago we would have
been over there along the side of the
mountain and there would have been a
shoreline actually not a lake bed 30
years ago the Great Salt Lake covered
some 3 000 square miles now at its
lowest level ever recorded it covers
less than a thousand that's why it's
important to do it now because
if you wait another five years it's just
going to be another record low if the
lake Bottom is completely dry the wind
picks up and it creates dust storms that
carries the urban areas like Salt Lake
City to figure out how severe those dust
storms could be scientists from the
University of Utah bike miles across
land that was once underwater Kevin
Perry is a professor of atmospheric
sciences and an expert in air quality
you can see this wall of dust and it
reduces the visibility and people are
very concerned about what might be in
the dust that they're breathing to
measure what is in the dust Perry uses
an instrument that in small scale mimics
a dust storm and what that does is it
creates a swirling wind inside this
chamber that simulates wind speeds of up
to about 50 miles an hour what he's
discovered in the dust raises serious
health concerns for the millions who
live in the Salt Lake City region and
unfortunately we found very high
concentrations of arsenic in the soil
and arsenic is concerning for a variety
of reasons it can lead to lung cancer
skin cancer bladder cancer
cardiovascular disease and diabetes how
does arsenic get into this
here the Arsenic is coming from is it
coming from industrial sources is it
coming from mines and the simple fact of
the matter is is that every measurement
that I took over all 800 square miles of
the lake bed was high in Arsenic and the
only way that that can happen is if it's
naturally occurring and has gradually
accumulated here in the lake bed over
thousands of years preventing arsenic
contaminated dust storms requires
getting more water into the Great Salt
Lake but that's not easy when Utah like
much of the West is in the grip of what
is now called a mega drought more than
20 years of below average precipitation
this is the Bear River it's fed by
melting snow from the mountains here and
it's the main source of water for the
Great Salt Lake but right now it's
flowing at just 15 percent of what it
would normally be doing at this time of
year the mega drought is a contributing
factor but the biggest problem is our
water use policies and the culture of
water not valuing water nearly enough
living in the Arid West okay here we go
Jules Ferry runs a farm along the Bear
River for five generations his family
has been using water from the river to
grow food and raise cattle every gallon
you take out of the Bear River is a
gallon that doesn't go to the lake at
the same time we have a way of life you
know we have water rights to take that
water and so what we try to do is we say
let's reduce the amount of water that
we're taking out of the Bear by doing
irrigation efficiency practices being
efficient has become a necessity last
year his water allocation was cut by 30
percent he has installed drip irrigation
for some of his crops other fields have
been carefully leveled to make better
use of flood irrigation so what we're
doing is really utilizing the water that
we have in a more efficient way to make
sure that there's enough to go around
agriculture uses about 65 percent of the
water that flows out of the Wasatch
mountains but demand for Water by Urban
users is rising fast as more people move
to the Salt Lake City area some need
municipalities even require that
homeowners plant and maintain grass
lawns
what's it like when you drive through
the suburbs and see those green Lawns
and flower gardens
what do you think there's not a lot of
economic value derived from that it
makes people feel good to have a green
lawn you know we're not the countryside
of England we're the West we're Utah is
the second driest state in the country
and we need to probably act like we are
Joel Ferry's commitment to saving water
on his farm is one reason he's starting
a new job the governor has asked me to
serve as the executive director of the
Department of Natural Resources it's
what oversees all water rights Water
Resources for the State Wildlife
Resources outdoor recreation all of
these things I'll be the boss his
challenge will be convincing Farmers
industry and City dwellers alike in Utah
to understand the vital importance of
water conservation we're creative we
settled the desert like we can make this
work not only to save the Great Salt
Lake but also to preserve a way of life
in one of the driest places in America
for CBS Saturday morning John Blackstone
at the Great Salt Lake
leave it to John Blackstone to come out
of retirement and tell us something we
didn't know I mean had no idea I was
just in Salt Lake City was just on the
Great Salt Lake and had no indication of
of this going on and people are in tune
to what goes on in in Utah and you
really see the effects I mean when we
talk about climate change just the
Ripple effects of what they're doing and
Common Sense policies that need to be
there when you talk when you see The
Lawns that are required to be green in
those neighborhoods I think of
California where it's so opposite
because they've been dealing with this
for so long and trying to find ways to
find water because they have right if
they're if their lawns are green you're
in trouble exactly